je vais vous parler de transparence et
je vous parlais de la transparence en
général que ça soit la transparence
philosophique la transparence en
politique où la transparence en
technologie la transparence fait naître
une sérendipité et une sérendipité
particulière cette sérendipité l arme
des foules qui s'en servent un peu
partout sur internet
elle va détruire beaucoup des marques
qui nous environne et elle va détruire
les marques en s'attaquant à notre
imaginaire parce que notre imaginaire
c'est le territoire des marques qui nous
entoure je veux faire une petite
démonstration on va prendre un
imaginaire vermeer peintre baroque du
xviie siècle qu'on connaît a priori tous
et là vous avez une marque qu'on connaît
tous aussi une très vieille marque val à
41 ans elle nous accompagne tous depuis
quatre décennies
et je vais vous montrer comment avec un
peu d'imagination on peut détruire une
marque
en pratique ça n'est qu'un jeu géant de
l'agroalimentaire qui fabrique dans une
usine des yaourts
ça n'a rien à voir avec l'artisanat
encore moins envers mes seins cette
petite chose que je viens de faire et
qui va définitivement vous poser
question à chaque fois que vous allez
revoir une publicité de la laitière
cette petite chose des meutes
d'internautes s'en saisissent
quotidiennement et sur internet vous
martèle les messages inattendue de la
sérendipité de façon à détruire des
marques
cet été vous êtes probablement pas
passer à côté de ça qui vous a rappelé
que toutes les marques ont une dimension
politique
et n'allez pas écouter les politiques
qui vont vous dire que c'est la faute à
internet c'est la faute aux réseaux
sociaux
les politiques sont les premiers à
utiliser la transparence pour régler un
problème critique
la confiance quand une intense crise de
confiance a touché le monde politique
français la première chose qu'ils ont
fait c'est voter une loi sur la
transparence
sap a beaucoup marché mais les
politiques ont oublié une dimension de
la transparence qui est précisément que
la transparence procède du déterminisme
technologique la transparence peut aussi
être utilisée par des experts de la
technologie comme réponse politique
vous connaissez tous wikileaks et n'est
pas manqué de constater que depuis
wikileaks
on ne compte plus les modes d'action
politique qui procède de la transparence
pour imposer une réalité et dès d'ouvrir
un mensonge et ça ne vous aura pas
échappé non plus que wikileaks s'est
accompagné d'une foule d'internautes
cette foule d'internautes c'est les
anonymous animus c'est quelque chose
d'absolument passionnant parce que c'est
le premier véritable mouvement social du
21e siècle
samour spécifique au 21ème siècle au
même titre que le syndicalisme était
spécifique au 19e siècle au même titre
que le syndicalisme et est spécifique à
la révolution industrielle anonymous est
spécifique à la révolution numérique et
depuis l'affairé wikileaks
les anonymous ont accompagné toutes les
grandes mouvement de protestation
sociale que se fait dans le monde arabe
que ce soit ici aux etats-unis à berlin
à paris en chine à istanbul où on
amérique du sud
les anonymous ont accompagné tous les
grands événements qui ont marqué les
populations jusqu'à très récemment en
france à nous c'est très intéressant
parce qu'il préfigure les contestations
sociales du 21e siècle et ses
contestations sociales vont s'opposer
aux états on l'a vu mais également aux
entreprises car on est mou s'est déjà
opposée à une multitude d'entreprises la
plus connue d'entre elles c'est celle ci
quatre ans avant que sony soit attaquée
par kim jong-un et ses redoutables
pirates 4 ans dans ce triste épisode qui
vaut très largement saddam hussein et
l'anthrax sony s'est fait attaquer par
d'autres types d'ennemis dans ce qui
s'est avéré être un véritable fukushima
digital sony s'est attaqué à anonymous
aidé d'un autre groupe de hackers nommé
nul sec et lui sait qu'à procéder à une
opération très simple ils ont pris ce
qui était auparavant de l'ordre du
secret chez sony les meilleurs aux
cartes de crédit des login des password
et ils les ont rendues publiques rendant
possible une multitude de piratage parce
que les utilisateurs du playstation
network qui sont comme vous ils
utilisent de même login même pas se voir
partout en fait à partir de manger votre
login password je peux aller partout
votre compte amazon votre compte paypal
l'intranet de votre entreprise et si
vous travaillez à l'essai ya c'est un
vrai problème
alors ça eu des conséquences dramatiques
pour sony là on voit un cours de bourse
de sony sur trois mois dans un premier
temps il ya eu fukushima forcément ça
fait beaucoup beaucoup de dégâts y
compris sur leurs cours de bourse
dans un second temps il ya eu anonymous
et dans un troisième temps l'arrivée de
ce fameux groupe de hackers lulzsec qui
a instrumentalisé en quelque sorte
anonymous instrumentaliser les foules si
on compare ça au nikkei que l'équivalent
du cac 40 sur le marché japonais
vous voyez que dans un premier temps
sony et lichens suis à peu près les
mêmes courbes et dans un second temps et
ben ça décroche et si on fait le bilan
et bien sony a perdu 3,5 milliards dans
cette période sur sa valorisation
boursière dont les deux tiers sont
imputables anonymous au final ce
fukushima digital aura coûté à sony 1,7
fois fukushima c'est colossal et dans
les éléments qui se sont dégradées dans
la valorisation sony au premier plan il
ya sa marque la marque sony parce que
figurez-vous que les marques sont
valorisé en bourse
au même titre que les entreprises une
partie de la valorisation d'une
entreprise en bourse c'est sa marque
quand elles portent évidemment une
marque connue du grand public
le problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui nous
rentrons dans un monde où la marque
c'est le talon d'achille d'une
entreprise les marques qui sont
valorisés en bourse on est content pas
il y en a une quantité absolument
astronomiques et leur prix peut parfois
atteindre des sommes qui sont
complètement folle apple cette année a
dépassé largement les 100 milliards de
dollars au total si vous prenez les 100
plus grandes marques au monde
on est sur une valorisation totale de
2,9 milliards de dollars
une énorme bulle une énorme bulle
constitué sur une relation entre un
capital de marque et un capital de
confiance
ce capital de marquise calcule de façon
assez scientifique
étonnamment sur la cohérence entre les
pratiques d'une entreprise et les
valeurs d'une marque et ça c'est
précisément ce que vont attaquer les
foules et elles vont les attaquer sur
des lieux vous connaissez tous facebook
twitter des choses comme ça vous tous
vous avez un compte facebook peut-être
un compte twitter et peut-être avez-vous
croisé il ya deux ans
cette sérendipité là quand leur anna
plaza s'est effondré au bangladesh tuant
des centaines de femmes et d'enfants
ouvriers etc au milieu des gravats et
des cadavres
on a trouvé des étiquettes benetton
mettant en valeur
l'incohérence totale entre les valeurs
portées par la marque benetton et les
pratiques de l'entreprise
le marque a disparu trente ans de
communication jeter à la poubelle
vous n'avez pas pu passer à côté de
cette sérendipité là lors du scandale de
la viande de cheval
là encore
des foules qui s'arme de sérendipité et
dans le monde arabe
vous n'avez n'auriez pas pu passer à
côté de cette sérendipité là durant tout
l'été qui a provoqué un effondrement des
parts de marché coca cola dans tout le
monde arabe
la problématique aujourd'hui c'est qu'on
est sur une entreprise qui est de plus
en plus dans une relation avec sa marque
qui est inspiré de dorian gray on a d'un
côté une marque public belge jeune
dynamique
de l'autre côté une entreprise qui est
rarement public
rarement jeunes est rarement dynamique
d'un côté on a des valeurs de l'autre
côté on a des pratiques d'un côté on a
un imaginaire de marque de l'autre côté
on a une réalité
d'un côté on a des consommateurs qui
sont une abstraction imaginé par des
publicitaires et de l'autre côté on a
des citoyens vous moi nous tous personne
ici ne peut être réduit à un simple
consommateur - d'une sérieuse de boto
mis la problématique dans lequel on
entre petit à petit c'est que cette
frontière qui existe entre le public et
le privé tout on a tous constaté les
placements avec facebook et l'usagé
pendant les adolescents cette frontière
elle existe aussi pour les entreprises
et petit à petit le domaine du privé de
l'entreprise devient de plus en plus
public et sous l'impulsion de la foule
petit à petit la vie privée de
l'entreprise devient public nous sommes
arrivés aujourd'hui à un moment où la
révolution numérique va forcer les
marques à appréhender la transparence à
ne pas lutter contre elle c'est comme
lutter contre la marée qui monte mais à
comprendre et manipuler cette
transparence et en tirer parti d'une
façon ou d'une autre la révolution
numérique va forcer les marques à
interagir avec cette foule plutôt que de
les subir
la révolution numérique va forcer les
marques à intégrer cette fameuse
sérendipité à la faire sienne à ne pas
en être victime
humains et enfin la révolution numérique
va forcer les marques à partager
l'imaginaire qui était autrefois leur
domaine exclusif commerci